oh hell
no move hey PG-13
please what was that Lord is the queen
bee Regina George don't look her in the
ey you could be really hot if you change
like everything I met ay inm in welcome
to Health and Human Sexuality we will be
getting abstinence of course Then
followed by in the spring condoms and
choking you're learning things now that
I don't know how to
teach are you okay in there we're
concerning either doing drugs or having
a toilet baby
ew we as women have to be able to
support each other get in loser welcome
Katie you're never going to believe what
I found this morning your burn book mom
go make snacks for sure for sure Regina
yeah do you like gum sure oh no I don't
have any I was just you're a mess we
will help you
caddy why are you dressed so scary it's
Halloween Katie if you don't dress
that is shaming us that's
just
unprofessional what what's
this we're going to make her
pay all we've done is to make Regina
hotter and revive the wet look dance
break
[Music]
who wrote all this
junk K pushed her Regina really should
be lifting through her
[Music]
glutes look at this thing I can't even
see it like a face
breast incorrect you have to pick a
French name Chanel No sheline
no
beon